the whole truth and nothing but the
truth it's the issue that's dogged him
and damaged him for more than a year I'm
here to say to you hand on heart that I
did not lie to the house we knew about
lockdown busting parties at Downing
Street but did the rule breaking extend
to Checkers with the Prime Minister
inviting friends to his official country
residence in buckinghamshire
while Boris Johnson has been touring the
world making speeches and making money
government lawyers have handed evidence
from his own ministerial Diaries to the
police
the assertion by the cabinet office that
there have been further covert rule
breaches is totally untrue lawyers have
examined the events in question and
advised that they were lawful no contact
was made with Mr Johnson before these
incorrect allegations were made both to
the police and to the Privileges
committee this is both bizarre and
unacceptable
and while Boris Johnson's allies want to
move on I'm just doing this now but my
sense of all of this is that frankly the
prime minister or former prime minister
has been through that we've investigated
that the country's dealt with that I
think the world's moved on quite frankly
and it raises further questions about
um the role of the Civil Service in all
of this opposition parties are angry
right now I think the Prime Minister
Ricky sunak needs to make sure that not
a single penny more is spent on Boris
Johnson's defense during his uh lying
inquiry and I think Boris Johnson in
light of everything that's happened
needs to consider whether really he
should be an MP I just believe it's
wrong that the taxpayer is continuing to
fund Boris Johnson's legal defense here
but she soon act should bring that to an
end and Boris Johnson will now have to
explain himself yet again to the
authorities this is just more sleaze
both the met and Thames Valley police
are now investigating if he saw a friend
on a social visit when you shouldn't
have
it will be fixed penalty notices um if
that was um if this that wasn't
um forming within one of the exceptions
and the rules so you know in the region
of 50 to 100 and something pounds
these latest Revelations could delay the
Privileges committee inquiry into
whether Mr Johnson misled Parliament and
yet again it dragged which is sunac into
answering questions about the past when
he's desperate to focus on the future
Andrew is in Downey Street tonight and
Joe the sense was a potential political
comeback for Boris Johnson had been
receding had it got uh even more remote
now do you think
I think it probably has Anna but the
real problem here I think is really for
a Rishi sunak on his first day at
Downing Street on the steps behind me he
promised Integrity professionalism
accountability every level of government
and yet bad headlines about bad past
alleged Behavior just seemed to not want
to stop you've got Boris Johnson and
partygate omnipresent you've got
recently Dominic Raab and how he treated
civil servants the dean zahawi's
finances and then in the past few days
and this speed awareness course and
issue which isn't yet resolved of course
these sort of mini scandals don't have
the prime minister at their heart
although Richardson Act of course was
fined for one party gate event but this
does tarnish I think those in number 10
I believe the conservative brand
something that of course wants to
burnish the head of the next general
election expected next year the other
issue here which I think is of concerned
some conservative MPS is the fact that
the Civil Service and the cabin office
were the ones to refer all of this
information to both the police and the
Privileges committee it feeds into a
worry a concern in some parts of the
conservative party the back benches that
some civil servants aren't being
entirely fair and balanced with how they
have worked with some conservative
ministers now of course senior Civil
Service central the Prime Minister would
contest that but it doesn't help Rishi
sunat in governing and that is difficult
when he has a lot of challenges on his
plate including immigration later this
week